we begin tonight Fox News Alert breaking
just moments ago Georgia congressman
Doug Collins has released eight
closed-door hearing transcripts from his
committees investigation into the FBI
and Obama's DOJ we now here comes is the
what I've been telling you cascading
down on the avalanche
we have scores of new transcripts from
Loretta Lynch either she or call me or
lie Andrew McCabe James rebecky and many
other high-ranking officials based on
these newly released documents we can
now confirm one major piece of
information the former attorney general
under Barack Obama that's right Lynch
through James Comey right under the bus
and told Congress she never asked the
embattled FBI director to refer to the
Clinton criminal investigation as they
matter Comey said just the opposite one
of them is lying who lied to Congress
who committed the crime under oath it
would be a serious violation oh yeah it
was important on the Trump side now
let's see the mainstream hate Trump
media Mob do them do their job on this
side we are combing through this
information each line of every
transcript we will have full analysis
Gregg Jarrett Sarah Carter Matt Gaetz
and so much more also breaking tonight
the president he just wrapped up a
raucous rally in Pennsylvania drawing a
way bigger crowd than any of his
Democratic challengers including Sleepy
creepy crazy uncle Joe now coming up
we're going to show you all the
highlights from tonight's speech but
first we have more big breaking news out
of the deep state we're gonna go slow
tonight we'll make sure we get it all in
I want to set the stage tonight is just
the beginning of what is coming every
day week month ahead and there is a ton
of it an avalanche of new information
new documents they will all reveal a
shocking level of corruption bias
lawlessness at the highest levels of the
deep state it's all about to be revealed
at this hour your federal government is
in possession of transcripts from 2016
featuring secretly recorded
conversations between FBI informants and
one-time Trump campaign ad Jorge Papa
topless according to those who have seen
these transcripts its contents are chock
full of clear irrefutable
incontrovertible exculpatory evidence
proving Trump Russia collusion was
always a hoax from the get-go now this
includes former congressman trey Gowdy
who is now calling these documents quote
game-changing let's take a look if the
bureau is gonna send an informant and
the informants going to be wired and if
the bureau is monitoring telephone calls
there's gonna be a transcript of that
and some of us have been fortunate
enough to know whether or not those
transcripts exist but they haven't been
made public and I think one in
particular is going it has the potential
to actually persuade people very little
on this Russia probe I'm afraid is going
to persuade people who hate Trump or who
love Trump but there is some information
in these transcripts that I think has
the potential to be a game changer if
it's ever made public this material must
be made available Oh where's Jerry
Nadler where is Oh mr. Oh Adam Schiff
the biggest liar in Congress the
cowardly shift because if Comey struck
other high-level officials the highest
level not not rank and file we always
make a distinction I have an FBI pin and
at CIA pin on tonight the 99% to protect
us every day but those in the FBI and
the CIA at the upper echelon the Intel
community or withholding exfol patria
vyd integrity
conspiracy against the FISA Court that
means there was a real attempt to steal
a presidential election with Russian
lies paid for by Hillary and an effort
to unseat when they lost a duly elected
president of you the people much worse
than we ever knew now keep in mind
Papadopoulos he was just one of several
Trump campaign members who in fact were
being surveilled by commis FBI and this
transcript is just one of the several
buckets we told you there's five of
information that will soon be revealed
we're also expecting the Declassified
FISA application against Carter page
that should reveal how Comey and others
totally completely relied on the phony
Clinton bought and paid for
Russian disinformation dossier that was
passed off as verified material and the
we now know they were warned repeatedly
that it was not now this weekend former
congressman Gowdy had this to say about
the deep states love affair with
Christopher Steele's unverifiable why
because he doesn't stand by it
dirty dossier take a look we can call it
a dossier it sounds official
it's really something the National
Enquirer would blush if they print it so
we know that it was used for Toms by the
United States government what we're
trying to figure out is whether or not
it was used a fifth time and the
intelligence assessment and you got
Brennan clapper and Comey or all three
who know full well whether or not it was
used in the intelligence assessment but
they're giving you different they're
giving you different versions now soon
if justice is served we will all have
access to the very same material the
trey gowdy reviewed as a sitting member
of congress and tonight good news
according to the freedom caucus chairman
mark meadows of north carolina and he's
talking about document releases that are
just around the corner as we've been
telling you let's take a look
I think the delays over I think the
president is series have spoken to him
recently and I think declassification is
right around the corner and hopefully
the American people will be able to
judge themselves now while we look
forward to the release of the FISA
applications the Papadopoulos transcript
one former FBI agent with the help of
Judicial Watch is now requesting a trove
of documents related to Andrew McCabe
operation mid-year exam that's the one
against Hillary of course for the server
and yeah then the intent was to destroy
they've subpoenaed emails thirty three
thousand of them and as you know McCabe
was commis second-in-command at the FBI
until he was fired and now there is a
criminal referral for quote repeated
lying and according to a brand new
report from Sarah Carter this evening a
retired FBI agent issued a FOIA request
for emails related to McCabe's wife and
the Clintons remember the case Jill
McCabe had deep ties to all world
Clinton launched the 2015 State
Senate campaign at the behest of the
Virginia Governor Clinton hack Terry
McAuliffe and McCabe's campaign even
accepted get this nearly a half a
million dollars from McCall owes
political action committee and another
292,000 from a second Democratic PAC now
let me just put this in perspective that
is an obscene unprecedented amount of
money for a little State Senate campaign
and frankly an obscene amount of money
for any such race now clearly this does
represent yet another conflict of
interest at the highest levels of the
FBI which clearly had their favorite
candidate in 2016 and we all know it was
not Donald Trump that's why there was an
exoneration before an investigation
that's why it's irrefutable
incontrovertible evidence she broke the
law violated the Espionage Act and had
the intent of destroying the evidence
when she deleted 33,000 subpoenaed
emails bleep spit the hard drive had an
aide bust up the devices and yanked out
the SIM cards but the chosen one Hillary
Clinton she was given that free pass
after she did all of this yes there was
classified top secret material then of
course the obstruction everything that I
now told you a free pass for obvious
crimes while the President of the United
States is forced to endure a nearly
three-year witch-hunt based entirely on
a hoax that they knew of from the get-go
when we get back to my monologue in just
a minute but first joining us now with
more on McCabe's conflicts of interest
Fox News investigative reporter Sarah
Carter you have been working on this
story for quite some time and it is now
about to be released yes so former
Supervisory Special Agent Jeffrey Dannic
has been fighting for over two years
Sean with judicial watch to get the text
messages of former and fired deputy
director Andrew McCabe apparently it is
a treasure trove it's not only going to
answer questions regarding his wife and
those issues but apparently there's a
lot more information contained in these
text messages and emails that the FBI
does not want to release now the
Department of Justice has been fighting
Judicial Watch on this in the courts and
Judicial Watch filed a motion
last week against the DOJ to release the
documents Judicial Watch is expecting
the DOJ to turn those documents over and
as you stated earlier Sean there is now
the official transcripts right here that
have been released by representative
Collins we're scouring through them just
as you are I think some of the most
interesting things that I've discovered
relate to Trisha Anderson now she was an
FBI national security lawyer and she was
working directly with James Baker as
well as Lisa page and in her transcripts
in the back and forth with the
questioners she talks about Bruce or in
the 302s she talks about the fact that
she basically signed off on the first
FISA warrant on Carter page and as you
stated earlier Carter page right now
there are transcripts expected to be
released of his conversations as well
with Stephane Halper very similar to
george papadapolis who was being probed
by stefan Halper who was the former
british professor who was gathering
information for the FBI and spying on
the Trump campaign the most interesting
fact I think and I'll leave you with
this Shawn is that Trisha Andersen
basically tries to downplay Bruce or his
involvement when they question about
being the back-channel for Christopher
steel after the FBI fired him and they
questioned her over and over again if
the FBI actually had enough evidence
enough evidence to go after a FISA with
what with what they found in the dossier
and Trisha Anderson refuses to answer on
multiple occasions so it's going to be
very interesting to see what comes out
next it's going to be very interesting
to see what the Department of Justice
William bar will Attorney General
William bar will have as far as
information on you know on the
investigation and how it coincides with
these transcripts I think people have a
lot of answering to do a lot of spying
you forgot the Bond movie blonde
bombshell Papadopoulos Sam Clovis
Papadopoulos Carter page FISA warrant a
lot o James Comey says that wasn't
spying and if he of course signed off on
the first FISA application and
/ 2016 verifying its true and accurate
but told Trump later
no it's unverified and now Loretta
Lynn's contradicting her testimony and
you were breaking news Sarah great job
thank you thank you
also breaking tonight we did learn that
the Muller investigators they were given
permission by the British government to
interview the dirty dossiers author
Christopher Steele yes that Christopher
Steele the guy who does not stand behind
his own dossier the Christopher steel in
an interrogatory under the threat of
perjury and I don't know if any of this
is true the same steel that was fired by
the FBI for lying and leaking the same
steel who was back-channeling we know
now information to Muller's
investigators after being fired through
Bruce or and of course did you get this
to the special counsel why would you
trust a liar and leaker and as you know
Muller concluded the Trump campaign did
not collude in any way with the Russian
government four separate investigations
so we can now deduce that Steele's
so-called Intel he doesn't stand by it
he thinks it's BS and it always was it
was James Comey his high ranking
deputies that swore that the contents
were true and accurate and the word
verified appears at the very top of the
FISA request application that was into
Carter page to get into all things Trump
campaign all things Trump transition and
all things Trump as president this is
why I've been calling it the biggest
abuse of power corruption scandal in our
history
just to recap the deputy FBI director
Andrew McCabe yes
Criminal Investigation referral fired
for lying lead investigators struck page
fired political bias or struck was and
Lisa page resigning General Counsel
Baker resigning reportedly facing a
criminal investigation himself for
leaking Combes chief of staff James
rebecky also leaving out 25 in total
between the State Department FBI fired
leaving in disgrace or demoted Bruce or
was once the fourth highest ranking
member at the DOJ and let's not forget
James Comey himself was fired from
mishandling the Clinton of
that's commis legacy turmoil bias
corruption at the highest levels of what
is right there
FBI pin the single greatest law
enforcement agency in the entire world
tainting the 99% of people that risk
their lives for us but if you listen to
mr. Comey who thinks he's smarter than
us smelly Walmart people he thinks he's
a super Patriot he knew better than the
American people oh he could do no wrong
whatsoever everyone else is bad everyone
else is evil
so naturally call me all too happy to
parrot now democratic talking points
about Attorney General bar writing on
Twitter the AG should stop slamming his
own Department if there are bad facts
show us or search for them
professionally then tell us what you
found and AG must act like the leader
the Department of Justice an
organization based on truth donald trump
has enough spokespeople Jim I suggest
the mirror to self take a look according
the Wall Street Journal bars fighting
back and reminding Comey he is fighting
for the presidency which is his rightful
duty in the executive branch and perhaps
Comey could use a refresher course on
how checks and balances work but really
James Comey search for them
professionally you're the same James
Comey that allowed Loretta Lynch to
dictate according to your testimony the
terms of the investigation into Hillary
Clinton or when you made no real attempt
to verify that phony Clinton bought and
paid for dossier as a matter of fact you
knew ahead of time it was you were told
by Bruce or ahead of time you knew from
the from the State Department ten days
earlier and you still did it using that
as the basis an unverified Russian
dossier paid for by Clinton but of
course you didn't tell the court Clinton
bought and paid for this garbage a FISA
warrant used to spy on the member of the
Trump campaign so you can spy on the
whole campaign although you don't call
signing a FISA application spying it is
by definition spying because now you're
bugging every single aspect of Carter
page and getting a sneak peek into all
things the world Trump or when you
leaked confidential notes on private
conversations you
had with the president to spur a special
council investigation
yeah is that professionally the search
for truth and justice at the FBI Jimbo
Jim Comey knows he's in deep trouble
tonight
the problem with Comey is I gave him
this warning a long time ago before that
dopey book of his came out you should
get off Twitter stop writing dumb books
stay away from fake new CNN and you do
have the right to remain silent
I keep suggesting you use it because the
truth is going to be revealed and
moments ago during a massive rally in
Pennsylvania the president he had this
to say about the disgusting deep state
corruption that took place under Jim
Comey's watch under the Biden Obama
administration the whole thing was under
their watch let's take a look this phony
witch-hunt that we all went through
together it's a disgrace
[Music]
now they're all blaming each other you
see they're all turning on each other
isn't that pretty - what it's his fault
though it's his fault
now we caught him they were spying they
were spying on our campaign I'll tell
you what if that ever happened to the
other side this thing would have been
over two years ago and you know it would
have been treason they would have called
it treason and that's what it is there
was treason and it should never be
allowed to happen to another president
again ever ever ever